bonjour Merci à vous merci à vous d'être
venu
on vient regarder notamment vos
infrastructures vu qu'il y a un projet
de rénovation des vestiaires qui je
pense n'est pas du luxe dire qu'on se
doute dans un truc comme ça comme je dis
on va au cèpe quoi chez nous c'est la
région donc voilà ça va au champignon ça
va pas au football quoi entre les
bactéries peuvent développer les douches
qui sont passées voilà les radiateurs à
l'ancienne qui peuvent mettre le feu à
tout moment
à vous de jouer messieurs les élus
bonjour je suis Julien Raoul député de
la troisième circonscription de l'Aude
donc je suis en quelque sorte un enfant
du pays j'ai grandi dans cette ruralité
et j'ai souhaité faire une proposition
visant à créer un fond d'investissement
pour les petites communes les communes
de moins de 3500 habitants qui
rencontrent aujourd'hui des difficultés
pour réaliser les investissements
nécessaires pour leur commune et donc je
vais vous amener avec moi de rencontrer
ces différents maires pour qu'il nous
explique leur difficulté
[Musique]
avant km au sud de Limoux dans la haute
vallée de l'Aude le maire voudrait
rénover les vestiaires de son stade il a
convié le député et ce changement
c'est surtout dans le dans les
vestiaires ou l'hiver ils doivent pas se
régaler
au niveau de l'hygiène c'est pas c'est
pas top
les douceurs
si l'électricité qui passe au dessus bon
il y a rien pour pour aérer donc voilà
[Musique]
les champignons sur le voilà les mycoses
c'est fabuleux et les plaques que tu
vois dessus
ce sont les plaques d'isolation des
fissoles c'est du polyuréthane expansé
et c'est un produit qui est assez rigide
on va on va casser les blocs et on va
les refaire propre
reste maintenant à trouver les 80.000
euros nécessaires pour les travaux car
le maire n'a plus les moyens
la commune est étranglée par l'inflation
jusqu'à présent elle payait 30 000 euros
de gaz et d'électricité par an
on passe donc sur les factures qui qui
explosent donc je sais aussi bien que
moi sur les petites communes c'est très
très compliqué
en plus
fin d'année 2022 par rapport à 23 on a
été impacté directement sur sur une
hausse de
19 à 200 euros
c'est la folie multiplié par 11 sur le
gaz tu t'es renseigné pour pour voir si
tu as droit à quelque chose un
abattement ou on a droit à l'endroit
si la commune mette 300 et 400000 euros
dans les fluides
dans deux ans trois ans je sais même pas
comment je vais payer les employés
voilà alors tenable non
a déjà dû couper le chauffage des salles
de sa commune il a stoppé tous ces
projets la situation inquiète le député
c'est la mort à petit feu de la ruralité
elle ne peuvent plus tout juste dans
leur budget pour pour assurer les
dépenses de fonctionnement et donc elles
ne peuvent plus assurer les les dépenses
les investissements indispensables pour
pour leur commune
alors Julien rancoul a déposé une
proposition de loi il veut créer un fond
de revitalisation de 400 millions
d'euros pour ces communes rurales une
aide supplémentaire versée par l'État
pour financer leurs projets
publics ici on se sent vraiment
abandonné et donc député j'essaie
justement
d'alerter d'alerter le gouvernement sur
sur la situation de
proposer des solutions à cette situation
notamment par la création de ce fond
pour les petites communes qui
permettraient justement de revitaliser
cette ruralité
sur ces terres autrefois de gauche la
défense du territoire dépasse les
couleurs politiques
à brousse et Villaret le maire cherche
des fonds pour restaurer ces deux
églises depuis 1905 elles sont à la
charge des communes une charge très
lourde pour les villages
on doit refaire tous les enduits
extérieurs les vitraux les toutes les
menuiseries les fenêtres les vitraux
tout ça les soubassements parce que
c'était des soubassements en amiante
donc on a des orienté il y a du bois il
faut vraiment tout reprendre quoi il y a
de la pierre il y a du ciment vraiment
très dur ce qui n'a rien à faire là donc
il y a vraiment un gros gros travail de
restauration à reprendre là pour vous
montrer vraiment dans quel état se
trouvent les vitraux de l'église de
Saint-Étienne on a on les a même
bouchées avec du papier bulle pour
éviter que les les bestioles rentre ou
même que le froid rentre si c'est quand
même des années état très très délabré
on le voit ils sont coupés il faut les
il faut les les changer les refaire de A
à Z et c'est ce qui coûte ça aussi très
très cher quoi de notre responsabilité
et de la responsabilité de l'État aussi
de prendre les choses en main c'est ça
il faut surtout pas que l'État oubli
soit
pour eux pas question de désacraliser et
de vendre cette église même si elle ne
sert occasionnellement c'est le
patrimoine rural c'est la ruralité c'est
la France tout simplement c'est la
France et se rattacher à un patrimoine à
une histoire à une culture à des
traditions mais ça nous permet encore
d'avoir un esprit un esprit d'équipe un
esprit de village et c'est essentiel ici
cela un coût rien que sur cette église
ces travaux sont estimés à 100.000 euros
et aujourd'hui les subventions ne
couvrent aucune petite partie de la
facture on peut espérer 25%. 30 on y
arrivera pas donc même sur 100000 euros
il reste il reste quand même une somme
énorme il faut sortir encore 60000 euros
une commune comme la nôtre avec un
budget à 400000 euros on passera on peut
pas se permettre de mettre 60000 euros
sur 400 000 dans une rénovation d'une
seule tranche de l'église voilà c'est
pour ça qu'on compte vraiment beaucoup
sur ce projet
les aides du département de la région et
les dotations ne suffisent plus face à
l'inflation ces mers ruraux veulent que
l'État les aides davantage
[Musique]
j'enclat au cœur du pays cathare 46
habitants à l'année
ici faute de moyens le maire et son
frère entretiennent eux-mêmes le village
et là par exemple on avait eu une
rupture de canalisations une
canalisation fonte qui s'est cassée bon
ben on n'a pas appelé un plombier Le
petit frère a pris son tractopelle on a
pris l'appel la pioche et on est allé
chercher le matériel pour réparer ça a
été fait dans la journée ça a été très
rapide personne n'a souffert de manque
d'eau pendant la journée touche la
plomberie la maçonnerie on touche un peu
près tout et c'est vrai que ça ça permet
de pouvoir faire beaucoup de travaux par
nous-mêmes justement pour éviter de
plonger avec les le peu de moyens que
les communes a donc à les économies vous
faites venir un plombier pour réparer un
cadalisation comme ça vous avez tout de
suite pour 1500 euros donc sur un milieu
de 5000 1500 euros ça compte c'est ces
trois jours ou quatre jours de vie de la
commune
donc tous les travaux toutes les petites
économies sont importantes
mais pour la chaussée il faut bien faire
appel à une entreprise
Julien renconcoule est venu constater
les difficultés que rencontre le maire
sur ce dossier le goudronnage devrait se
faire normalement
fin du mois de mai début du mois de juin
mais bon vous voyez les gouffres de
partout sur la route sur le traitement
de suite c'est ça empire ça empire et
dans son délire
rien que pour cette route le cou est
important impossible à assumer sans aide
le problème c'est qu'on avait demandé
les subventions il y a trois ans de ça
le devis de il y a 2h30 en arrière vu le
prix des matières premières maintenant
je sais pas à quel niveau on va arriver
on arrivera peut-être à 35000 auquel cas
ce sera 10 000 de plus pour la commune
parce que les réponses du département et
de la région ontardé le maire a dû
reporter tous ses autres projets la
place de la mairie est complètement
défoncée a été prévu une roman de la
faire cette année mais avec le retard
qui a eu sur les noms de subventions sur
les donc on a deux ans de retard ce sera
le projet futur pour dans deux ans de
plus
une petite commune vous avez énormément
de voirie au final proportionnellement
au nombre d'habitants vous avez des
hameaux vous avez énormément de boire et
communales donc c'est vraiment un poids
qui pèse sur la sur les finances de la
commune donc c'est pour ça qu'on a
intégré j'ai intégré ce cet aspect c'est
dépenses là dans le fond qui qui n'est
aujourd'hui pas couvert par les
subventions d'états existantes
[Musique]
sur les plateaux des Pyrénées le maire
de rodom lui Lutz contre la
désertification pour revitaliser son
village isolé il rénove les appartements
de la commune ici c'est l'ancienne poste
donc c'est un appartement qu'on a
restauré donc il y a trois chambres
salle à manger cuisine
peinture etc etc faut savoir que là
c'est tout un échange de la commune tout
est à charger la commune donc ça c'est
le deuxième appartement on en a quatre
donc ça c'est le deuxième qu'on fait le
premier on a eu pour 14000 € et celui-ci
un appartement celui-ci pour le moment
qu'on est à 8000 euros c'est pas fini
voilà cet appartement à loyer modéré
sera bientôt remis en location au total
ces quatre logements rapportent 18000
euros par an au village une rentrée non
négligeable mais surtout des habitants à
l'année en plus deux enfants ce serait
bien un couple deux enfants ok voilà et
ça serait marcher aussi l'épicerie parce
qu'on a une épicerie à la mairie une
épicerie communale
avec le gaz du congelé des produits
locaux moi c'est mon c'est mon projet de
faire vivre le village quoi c'est
important cinq combats de tous les jours
l'autre combat c'est celui des aides
entre les aides à la rénovation auxquels
il n'a pas le droit et celle pour
lesquelles il faut déposer des dossiers
complexes
c'est mon point de vue on a le
département
de l'État la Région
c'est hyper compliqué voilà nous on a
les petites communes aujourd'hui les
maires ils ont pas de secrétaire les
mères sont foutus il y a une
complexification si jamais vous pouvez
simplifier les choses ce sera
énorme un guichet unique pour regrouper
et simplifier les demandes l'idée c'est
durera peut-être le député il espère
déjà pouvoir défendre sa proposition de
loi à l'Assemblée
c'est un choix politique en fait l'état
pour moi doit mettre les moyens dans la
ruralité pour la permettre déjà de
survivre mais aussi d'être plus
ambitieuse et d'être vraiment dans
l'avenir tout simplement et comment
l'État de finance
encore une fois c'est un choix c'est un
choix politique 400 millions d'euros
c'est assumable par l'État c'est un
choix politique on peut
j'ai parlé de la politique de la ville
je pense qu'on peut récupérer une partie
de des fonds de la politique de la ville
vers la ruralité ça me semble pas un
choix
[Musique]
négatifs et campagne
Julien rancoul va surtout devoir
convaincre les députés de dépenser plus
pour ces territoires jusqu'à présent
aucune proposition de loi du
rassemblement national n'a été votée en
France 90% des communes ont moins de
3500 habitants
[Musique]